Jean-Jacques Bourdin il est 8h34 bonjour
à toutes et à tous 8h30 9h l'interview
politique les Français veulent savoir
parlons vrai ce matin avec François
baayerou bonjour bonjour merci d'être
avec nous François Baayou le projet de
loi immigration vous savez ce que je
vais faire je vais reprendre le trajet
de ce texte de ce projet de loi tant
désiré par Gérald daranin le texte du
gouvernement est d'abord réécrit par le
Sénat puis réécrit par la commission des
lois de l'Assemblée nationale puis
rejeté par l'Assemblée nationale motion
de rejet sans avoir été examiné puis
réécrit par la commission mixte
paritaire puis adopté par les députés
sans avoir été discuté en séance
publique sans débat et maintenant le
Conseil constitutionnel qui va à son
tour réécrire cette loi est-ce
l'instance politique d'appel du
Parlement le Conseil constitutionnel non
je pense que il faut pas voir les choses
comme
ça et ça n'est pas réécrire la loi le
Conseil constitutionnel n'écrit rien il
n'écrit rien mais il va la modifier il
peut effacer mais il nécrit rien alors
il faut distinguer deux sujets dans la
présentation que vous venez de faire le
premier sujet c'est le processus
d'adoption le modèle d'adoption de ce
texte qui est pour moi très
insatisfaisant et on va voir où est la
responsabilité et la deuxième chose
c'est la légitimité de ce texte ou d'un
texte sur l'immigration et je pense que
cette légitimité est entière je pense
qu'un texte pas nécessairement celui-là
était absolument nécessaire parce que ce
que je vois sur le terrain je suis comme
vous l'avez rappelé maire de peau ce que
je je vois sur le terrain c'est une
inhumanité de la situation actuelle
actuelle et donc cette situation là une
intervention du
législateur qui aurait dû être pleine et
entière pour la changer était légitime
alors un sur le processus
oui ce processus a subi un accident et
qui est pour
moi absolument inacceptable et même une
négtion de tout ce que nous disons au
français et de ce que nos institutions
disent parce que ce texte aurait dû être
a été c'est le choix du gouvernement
examiné d'abord par le Sénat h pour
peut-être constituer une majorité qui
puisse assurer son passage il est venu
ensuite à l'Assemblée national il a été
tout à fait légitimement travaillé par
les commissions de l'Assemblée nationale
et puis fait absolument sans précédent
fait inédit et scandaleux l'Assemblée
nationale a dit et ben écoutez nous nous
ne l'examinerons pas les oppositions
allié de l'extrême gauche à la gauche
toute la gauche et l'extrême droite les
et la droite et la droite les les
oppositions alliées ont refusé de faire
le travail pour lequel elles sont élues
pour lequel les Français ont élu les
députés chacun des députés est venu
devant les électeurs en disant mais nous
nous allons faire la loi et nous allons
la faire bien nous allons défendre vos
idées ils ont refusé de faire ça je vous
confie quelque chose euh j'ai reçu
beaucoup de messages pendant cette phase
ultime de députés qui me disait tout à
fait de manière tout à fait sympathique
on compte sur vous
comment faire pour rectifier ce qui doit
l'être je dis mais c'est vous qui avez
refusé d'examiner vous avez fait sans
précédent depuis le début de la 5e
République vous avez refusé vous députés
élu pour faire la loi vous avez refusé
d'examiner le texte c'est la première
fois qu'un texte comme ça de cette ance
sur le auquel qu'on soit pour ou contre
François bairou vous savez bien que le
ministre de l'Intérieur pensait que son
texte que la motion de Roget n'allait
pas être adoptée vous le savez bien il y
a pas n'y a-t-il pas eu là un peu de
suffisance un peu de franchement je je
ne je ne suis pas là pour faire le
procès mais il s'agit pas de faire le
procès s'agit de dire la réalité des
choses donc je je pense qu'il y a eu des
erreurs d'appréciation je n'ai aucun
doute sur ce point et je pense que tout
le monde le sait y compris les
intéressés eux-mêmes mais écoutez bien
oui tous ceux qui disent on aurait
jamais dû laisser passer telle ou telle
disposition on peut-être on peut
réfléchir et voir lesquel on va parler
des des dispositions oui tout cela qui
ne vous plaisent pas d'ailleurs tout
cela ont ont refusé de jouer leur rôle
dans l'examen du texte j'ai dit à ces
députés mais écoutez si vous on avait
examiné le texte on aurait pu trouver
article par article oui mesure par
mesure disposition par disposition des
majorités de l'Assemblée nationale et
l'Assemblée nationale aurait eu un texte
à a opposé ou à équilibré au texte du
Sénat on a refusé de faire ça et c'est
démocratiquement inacceptable et la
faute en revient à ceux qui ont refusé
sous les applaudissements dans dans les
éclats de rire qui ont refusé de faire
leur travail et d'examiner le texte bien
bien mais maintenant il y a une réalité
la réalité c'est qu'il y a un texte un
texte qui a été voté par le le Parlement
un texte beaucoup plus dur que le texte
initial les députés
pardon pardon mais constatons les choses
les députés ont voté des articles en
espérant une censure par le Conseil
constitutionnel certains députés le
ministre de l'Intérieur lui-même a
soutenu un projet dont il dit qu'il
pourrait être en partie rejeté par le
Conseil constitutionnel jusqu'au
président de la République qui a mis
toute son autorité pour faire voter ce
texte et a saisi ensuite le Conseil
constitutionnel hier il a saisi le conse
constitutionnel hier Élisabeth Borme a
confirmé hier matin avoir des doutes sur
certaines mesures de la loi franchement
franchement avez-vous déjà vu une
majorité espérer que son texte soit
censuré par le Conseil constition ce
n'est pas le texte de la majorité c'est
c'est peut-être faut-il rappel ça texte
voté par la majorité c'est un texte voté
parce que il fallait bien trouver une
issue à ce débat qu'est-ce que vous me
diriez ce matin si le texte avait été
retiré vous diriez mais enfin François
Baayou ça n'est pas possible est-ce que
vous vous rendez compte que vous avez
devant les Français proposer un texte au
vote c'est Bourdin qui parle par ma voix
hein vous avez proposé un texte au vote
et vous avez été au bout du compte
obligé de le retirer alors que la
situation vous le savez bien sur le
terrain est insupportable on va y
revenir à la situation sur le terrain
mais c'est ça que vous diriez vous
diriez mais enfin c'est un gouvernement
d'incapable vous diriez-vous Bourdin
parle il monsieur Baou c'est un
gouvernement d'incapable c'est une
majorité un peu incapable de faire
adopter un texte c'est ça que vous
diriez ce matin et donc le ce que je dis
moi d'abord
un c'est absolument dans la Constitution
oui que quand il a un doute oui le
président de la République a la faculté
de soumettre ce texte à l'examen du
Conseil constitutionnel oui c'est
évident absolument nos institutions il
le fait bah écoutez c'est
son est-ce que est-ce que il est déjà
arrivé que des gouvernements je me
souviens très très bien devant un texte
qui ne leur plaisait pas disent ben le
Conseil constitutionnel se prononcera on
fait comme si c'est on fait comme si le
plus le plus légal le plus
institutionnel de nos mécanismes
d'examen des textes qu'on vote était
surprenant ou un scandale si la loi est
vidée de la plupart de ces articles ou
de ces principaux articles que se
passe-t-il elle ne sera pas vidée de la
plupart de ces princip 20 à 30 articles
sur 80 ou 85 voir ce que dit le Conseil
constitutionnel bon bon on verra
effectivement nous verrons mais
conditionnement des prestations sociales
non contributives instauration de côas
migratoire limitation du droit du sol
délit de séjour
irrégulier resserrement du regroupement
familial restriction du droit du sol ça
ce sont des des des mesures des articles
qui risquent
d'être qu'est-ce que vous appelez
restriction du droit du sol
traduisons vous employez enfin le monde
médiatique l'univers médiatique emploie
des mots qui ont l'air de d'immenses
atteintes à nos principes les plus
sacrés regardons vous dites restriction
du droit du sol je vais vous dire
exactement ce que c'est c'est la loi dit
pour que un un jeune homme ou une jeune
fille qui va devenir français parce
qu'il est né en France au moment de
devenir français il est normal qu'on lui
demande si elle le veut ou si c'est
contre son gré ou si elle s'en fiche
demander entre 16 et 18 ans 16 et 18 ans
oui à une jeune fille ou un jeune garçon
qui veut devenir français de le dire
hein de de de signer une déclaration en
disant oui c'est en pleine conscience
que je souhaite devenir français est-ce
que c'est une atteinte à quoi que ce
soit personnellement je ne me prononce
pas je vous pose simplement la question
je dis
simplement Fran Baou je dis que le
Conseil constitutionnel risque de revoir
votre copie vous le savez bien mais
c'est pas ma copie ni la COP du
gouvernement non des
députés de
l'opposition de qui alors de qui c'est
la copie qui est sortie de la
délibération de ce qu'on appelle la
commission
c'estàdire ce petit groupe de se députés
et se sénateurs oui qui essaie de
trouver un accord entre les deux
chambres pour faire adopter un texte
vous vous rendez compte que vous avez
fait adopter un texte réécrit par se
députés se sénateurs et bien pourquoi
alors est-ce qu'on a refusé de
entendez l'indignation dans votre voix
oui et et vous relayez ce que j'ai dit à
l'instant à votre micro je suis ou il
est il est scandaleux et
démocratiquement un scandale oui que les
députés élus pour cela
euh envoyés par les
citoyens pour voter la loi et dit par
sectarisme et bien nous refusons de
l'examiner et viennent après drapé dans
des principes qui leur rendent bien
service à cet instant et qui servent
évidemment à dissimuler leur leur
abandon ou leur démission ils viennent
dire c'est pas possible mais pourquoi tu
n'as pas examiné pourquoi tu n'as pas
voté qu'est-ce que tu viens faire à
l'Assemblée si tu es de ceux qui
prétendent affirment qu'il fallait pas
examiner ce texte et alors si vous me
permettez d'aller une phrase plus loin
pour vous donner
l'asion on y vient oui mais parce que le
temps passe quelle est la signification
oui du combat de ceux qui ne voulaient
pas d'un texte c'est qui veulent que
dure la situation actuelle et la
situation actuelle pour moi elle est pas
seulement inacceptableelle este par
inhumaine tous les joursou jours oui
alors un mot sur la caution demander aux
étudiants étrangers pour venir suivre
leurs études en France comme vous savez
vous y êtes opposé j'imagine je ne sais
pasah si si vous aviez écouté les
déclarations mais je comprends que vous
préfériez je comprends que vous
préfériez les déclarations à votre micro
déclaration aux autres micros mais mais
voilà mais on peut pas toujours être
chez vous et donc et donc
cette cette caution
oui c'est le contraire de nos principes
et de nos intérêts à une exception prê
que je veux être honnête en
notant pourquoi c'est le contraire parce
que nous avons besoin d'avoir un
rayonnement de la France par
l'intermédiaire des étudiants qu'elle
forment la francophonie et pas seulement
la langue française mais notre manière
de vivre et nos manières de penser je
pense à la laïcité par exemple elles ont
tout à gagner à ce que des étudiants
venus de l'étranger faire leurs études
en France et puisse
relayer ce qu'est la au fond le modèle
de société français mais faut être
honnête en disant que oui dans un nombre
non négligeable de cas il agit d'une
filière d'immigration dissimulée mais ça
il y a qu'à faire le travail des
universitaair mettre des examens mettre
des concours faire ce qu'il faut pour
qu'on s'assure que c'est vraiment la
volonté d'étudier et la volonté de
prendre en compte et de respecter ce
qu'est ce qu'est la France pour le reste
je suis absolument opposé à l'idée qu'on
fasse un tri parmi les étudiants en
fonction des moyens de leur famille j'y
suis opposé parce
que beaucoup beaucoup qui ont honoré la
France j'ai cité l'autre jour un autre
micro l'exemple de saintgor saintgor il
vient d'une famille sans moyens réel il
vient de très loin dans la culture quand
il arrive du Sénégal en France et puis
il sera agrégé et puis il sera le grand
homme d'État du Sénégal et le premier
président du
Sénégal bon ça
c'est c'est un exemple vivant c'est un
c'est un c'est un emblème de ce que la
France est capable de faire donc la
c'est un emblème réforme de la me est-ce
que vous n'avez pas le pistolet sur la
temp pardon de vous d'employer cette
expression mais vous vous êtes engagé à
réformer laame non non non la première
ministre a eu un contact avec le
président du Sénat en disant que s'il y
avait a examiner qu'est-ce que
c'esté non c'est pas ce que je dis c'est
la première ministre qui le dira euh ou
le le président du Sénat qu'est-ce que
c'est cette affaire c'est assez simple
euh il y a des gens qui disent euh et je
suis persuadé que c'est pas seulement
une erreur mais une faute lorsque vous
avez des étrangers malade sur votre sol
ne les soignez pas euh et moi je pense
que c'est du point de vue humain h et du
point de vue de la sécurité de la santé
des Français ça n'est pas acceptable
vous avez un tuberculeux qui arrive
après avoir traversé les épreuves
innombrables que cette vie de de
d'immigrés
d'émigré suppose il est tuberculeux vous
allez pas le soigner et on va avoir
ainsi une source de contagion la
première ministre a été obligé d'écrire
au président du Sénat pour lui dire
écoutez pour faire plaisir au LR on va
envisager une réforme de la me moi moi
ça n'est pas la démarche que j'adopte
mais cette démarche elle a été dictée
par une seule chose c'est que il n'y
avait pas de majorité absolue à
l'Assemblée nationale et si je crois ce
que je si je vois ce que je sens il y
aura pas de longtemps des majorités
absolues il faut apprendre à vivre ça
avec le pluralisme en tenant compte des
sensibilités différentes sans se laisser
compromettre et dériver TR questions
parce qu'il faut première question que
vous allez poser c'est pourquoi vous
dites que c'est inhumain la situation
Act vous poser la question parce que le
patronat nous dit le patronat nous dit
nous avons besoin de millions sur les
années qui viennent sur plusieurs années
de millions de travailleurs étrangers
pour notre économie pour l'économie
française comme vous savez c'est ce qui
a été fait par l'Allemagne qui a laissé
rentrer 1 million de personnes d'un seul
coup l'Italie
450000 moi mon mon point de vue c'est
que cette démarche ou cette présentation
là est dangereuse parce que si vous
comptez pour équilibrer les défaillances
de la démographie française si vous
comptez sur des apports venus de
l'extérieur alors vous allez créer des
problèmes
culturels parce
que les apports de population ils sont
acceptable quand c'est
proportionnellement léger ou
proportionnellement équilibré
ils deviennent inacceptable dès
l'instant que vous avez le nombre qui
qui qui donne le sentiment qui donne le
sentiment de changer la
natureut la nature du peuple que nous
formons ensemble et donc les quotas ça
très souvent été discuté délibéré donc
bon mais moi je veux vous dire la
situation actuelle allez-y parce que
personne n'en parle de la situation
actuelle et si nous n'avons rien fait
c'est cette situation actuelle qui était
appelée à perdurer au travers du temps
vous savez ce que c'est la situation
actuelle c'est des milliers de jeunes
hommes sur le territoire français qui
sont logés dans des hôtels
réquisitionnés à la frontière des villes
avec interdiction de
travailler interdiction d'activité
autrement dit et ils sont là pour des
années et des années ils sont au frais
logés au frais de la collectivité et ils
sont maintenus dans une situation dans
laquelle il n a évidemment toutes les
raisons pour vérifier que l'oisiveté est
la merre de toutes les dérives vous
savez àau on a eu comme vous
savez une personne qui s'occupait des
associations dédié au réfugiés qui a été
poignardé et qui est mortoui oui tout ça
le si l'on ne se rend pas compte du
caractère euh euh euh révolt temps de la
situation dans laquelle nous en fermant
les yeux en ayant bonne conscience mais
dans laquelle nous maintenons ces jeunes
garçons nous à PO on les fait jouer au
foot parce que parce qu'il faut bien
essayer de leur trouver quelque chose
d'une passion pour les pour les occuper
ils sont des milliers et des milliers et
moi je pense que c'est cette situation
là d'abord qui est inacceptable on peut
pas laisser pour des années et des
années parce que vous savez il y a une
décision en disant vous avez pas le
droit d'être là et puis après des
recours et des recours et qu'est-ce qui
se passe ça veut dire que le droit
d'asile que nous défendons il est
complètement dévoyé dévoyé détourné
parce que c'est pas d'asile qu'il s'agit
c'est d'une filière d'immigration qui
passe par la demande du droit d'asile et
par les recours innombrables qui sont
fait après et qui durent des années et
bien ça c'est pas possible et ce texte a
le mérite d'une accél tion de ces
procédures qui permettra au moins
d'avoir un traitement important mais il
y a une deuxième chose à dire c'est que
le texte le plus important pour la
régulation de l'immigration c'est pas en
France hier qu'il a été c'est en Europe
oui les européens se sont mis d'accord
personne nen a parlé hier et pourtant
c'est très
importantreô renforcé je vais aller vite
François Baou contrôle renforcé des
arrivées de migrants dans l'Union
européenne centre fermé près des
frontières pour renvoyer ceux n'ayant
pas droit à l'asile en Europe et
mécanisme de solidarité obligatoire
entre pays membres oui ou prise en
charge financière selon vous voyez bien
à quel ça change les choses oui bah bien
sûr non mais je ne sais pas si on va
arriver à l'appliquer c'est compliqué
oui il faut des moyens oui mais ça
change les choses avoir décidé entre les
pays européens de sortir de l'isolement
qui nous rend impuissant pour décider
ensemble qu'on va mettre en place des
règles et les faire resp c'est l'Europe
qui décide pour nous c'est pas l'Europe
c'est nous l'Europe c'est une
proposition française dis ça parce que
on entend partout hein c'est une
proposition française oui et c'est la
France et les députés européens en
particulier de notre groupe qui on vé
pour qui ont fait ce qu'il fallait pour
que ce texte soit pris et que les choses
changent réellement et enfin puisqu'il
va y avoir le tous les moyens de repérer
d'identifier et de faire que on n pas
les dérives qu'on connaît aujourd'hui et
donc de ce point de vue là c'est un
c'est un très grand progrès alors j'ai
deux questions politiques à vous poser
François baerou qui n'ont pas été posé
hier au président de la République
est-ce que le Président de la République
doit maintenant changer de Premier
ministre vous n'êtes pas président de la
République voilà fr c'est ce que vous
allez me répondre pour l'instant tout
pour l'instant d'accord pour l'instant
bah nous avons droit au sourire vous et
moi et donc euh oui c'est la
responsabilité personnel du Président de
la République est-ce qu'il doit changer
de gouvernement dans tous les cas je
pense qu'il va falloir un nouveau départ
et et et je pense que tout
ça a été éclairé parce que nous avons
vécu ces dernières semaines et et depuis
un an il faut donner un nouveau un
nouvel élan c'est ce que vous voulez
dire pas seulement je pense que
l'émission hier soir du président de la
République a eu un très grand mérite
c'est que on a tout d'un coup mieux vu
où était le cap qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
que ces gouvernements successifs ont
l'intention de faire pour rendre à la
France sa capacité sa souveraineté comme
on dit c'est-à-dire les moyens de
reprendre le contrôle de son avenir par
exemple dans la
réindustrialisation pour laquelle je me
suis battu beaucoup
beaucoup par exemple pour effacer les
problèmes de commerce extérieur c'est
pas normal que nous ayons les déficits
que nous avons euh par exemple pour que
l'agriculture soit prise en compte tout
ça et pour que
l'éducation retrouve ce qui ce qui doit
être comment dire le visage de la France
ce que doit être le le message de la
France à l'égard des siens et à l'égard
du monde qui nous regarde et il y a de
ce point de vuelà un un très gros
travail à faire donc on a on a mieux vu
hier soir le cap et le l'énergie que
suppose le fait contre vents et Maré
contre vent et
Maré d'avoir à à impulser ou à ou à
provoquer le mouvement du pays qui en a
bien besoin parce que la situation
actuelle pour moi et depuis longtemps
n'est pas acceptable merci François Baou
d'être venu nous voir ce matin sur
l'antenne de Sud Radio il est 8h58 pour